hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute gibt es ein brötchen rezept und
zwar habe ich dinkel weizen vollkommen
brötchen gebacken die brötchen bestehen
so 60 prozent aus dinkel zu 50 prozent
aus weizen und ich habe auch hier in
diesem rezept das mehl selbst gemahlen
das heißt ich habe mein eigenes
vollkornmehl verwendet aus dinkel und
weizenkörner und bei diesem rezept ist
es so die brötchen sind einfach zu
machen also von der verarbeitung herbst
aber man muss viel zeit einberechnen das
heißt wenn ich am sonntag die brötchen
haben möchte muss ich schon am freitag
den teig ansätzen samstag den teig dann
falken und stretchen und am sonntag kann
ich sie dann backen
also wenn ihr frühstücksbrötchen haben
möchtet dann könnt ihr einfach auf
meinem blog ja und da steht und noch mal
die genaue zubereitungs weise und vor
allem die uhrzeit mit dabei so dass man
wirklich sonntags früh frische brötchen
hat was ich ganz gut finde ich habe
jetzt die menge für 30 brötchen und ihr
könnt die auch wirklich die gesamte
menge machen und die brötchen dann auch
einfrieren und dann einfach bei bedarf
fünf minuten im backofen auf backen und
da habt ihr eben auch frische brötchen
die brötchen müssen nicht extra geformt
werden das heißt sie werden geschnitten
so sieht jedes brötchen noch individuell
aus aber richtig schön aus und ihr hört
auch schon von außen ist er richtig
schön knusprig das ist sogar noch warm
und von ihnen richtig schön luftig und
locker und vor allem durch das
vollkornmehl habe ich richtig den
kräftigen geschmack mit dabei wirklich
die kompletten nährstoffen
ballaststoffen mineralstoffe mit dabei
und es ist sozusagen wirklich auch nicht
besonders brötchen und das recht hat
einfach sehr lecker und es schmeckt auch
seine kam und ich spanne euch jetzt
nicht länger auf die folter sondern
zeigt euch jetzt mal die zutaten die ihr
für diese vollkornbrötchen benötigt mit
den sauerteig brauche ich 400 gramm
dinkel körner 400 gramm hefe wasser für
den vortrag brauche ich noch mal 400
gramm dinkel körner 5 133 gramm
weizenkörner 666 gramm wasser und 28
gramm salz
für dieses rezept könnt ihr natürlich
auch weizen vollkornmehl und
dinkelvollkornbrot gemahl und kaufen
aber ich finde dass es immer besser das
korn selber zu malen denn man hat er
wirklich noch alle tollen nährstoffe mit
dabei und vor allem riecht und schmeckt
man es wirklich
jetzt kommt das ganze also die kölner
kommen jetzt gegen eine getreidemühle
richtig gut und die werden jetzt ganz
fein gemahlen und das mache ich jetzt
einfach nacheinander die ersten dinkel
vollen körben
die werde ich jetzt malen und dann hier
ein umfüllen hier weil ich nämlich den
sauerteig machen und die nächsten zweite
kann ich alle in eine schüssel fallen
lassen denn das wetter an der vorteil
das mehl ist fertig das gebe ich drinnen
eine große schüssel
das werde jetzt eine sauerteig das heißt
hier kommt jetzt das hefe wasser drauf
und jetzt wird gleich alles gut
durchgemischt um zeit zu sparen
stelle ich jetzt hier nochmal die
schüssel drunter und gebe jetzt gleich
auch noch mal diese dinkel könne rein
und danach auch gleich die weizenkörner
um daraus dann den vorteig zuzubereiten
die kölner sind jetzt gemahlen jetzt
kann ich den vortrag machen das heißt
hier kommt noch das salz mit dazu und
das wasser und das mache ich jetzt hier
in der schüssel die ist nämlich schön
groß und das ganze wird jetzt einfach
gut durchgeführt das könnte den
kochlöffel nehmen oder auch einfach die
hand nehmen
was eben besser geht
den sauerteig habe ich bereits abgedeckt
jetzt denke ich noch den vorteil ab und
dann kann ich beides über nacht bei
raumtemperatur stehen lassen
für etwa zwölf bis 15 stunden so sehen
jetzt beide tage nach der wartezeit aus
und jetzt muss ich beide verbinden und
frau auch gleich noch zwei zutaten und
zwar habe ich jetzt hier 90 gramm wasser
und 53 gramm olivenöl
zuerst werde jetzt beide tage verbunden
das heißt ich gebe den vortrag zum
sortiment und verknetet es jetzt gut
jetzt kommt das wasser betreiben und
jetzt kneten bis das wasser vollständig
mit dem teig verbunden ist
jetzt kommt das olivenöl noch mit dazu
und jetzt auch noch mal bissig nähten
ich würde sagen ordentlich kneten aber
das ist echt fast keine kinderarbeit
geht fast von ganz alleine
so sieht der teig jetzt aus und den
werde ich jetzt gleich noch mal
aufführen lassen
dafür nehme ich jetzt eine große
schüssel ich nämlich eine rechteckige
und die wird jetzt gefettet das ganze
feld denn meine schlüssel ich nicht ganz
ideal wird unseren paris
aber das ist in so weiter schlimm jetzt
auch ein olivenöl genommen jetzt kommt
hier datei klein und ihr seht jetzt auch
schon an der konsistenz der ich noch
sehr weich und den könnte ich jetzt
nicht so brötchen formen und ich zeige
euch gleich wie man das macht um den
teig gleich wieder in form zu bekommen
muss ich den teig jetzt falten davon
habt ihr vielleicht schon gehört wollten
stretch das heißt er wird jetzt
gestreckt und gefaltet so kann ich ja
den teig gar nicht in form bringen da
fällt ja immer auseinander wie bei wolle
zum beispiel wenn ich jetzt wolle
einfach nehme und zusammendrücken bleibt
sie nicht in form
ich muss sie auf rollen das heißt ich
rolle sozusagen den teig auf eine eckige
form ist deswegen gut weil man sich gut
merken kann welche seite muss ich jetzt
als nächstes falten
das heißt hände in wasser dann klebt
nicht jetzt von außen den teig fassen
und jetzt ziehen und in die mitte falten
und jetzt die gegenüberliegende seite
von außen nehmen ziehen und falten
hoppalas gerissen beim nächsten mal
jetzt besser
und jetzt die zwei übrigen seiten hoch
zu halten
und hochziehen und falten
und jetzt muss ich den teig noch drehen
das heißt so dass die naht sozusagen
unten ist
den teig weil ich jetzt abdecken und in
der nächsten runde zeige ich euch das
ganze noch einmal und da braucht jetzt
eine stunde ruht seit das heißt ich
stelle jetzt einfach abgedeckt hier
wieder in die küche bei raumtemperatur
passiert eine stunde auf gehen und den
vorgang werde ich dann noch zwei mal
machen
nachteil kann ich den tigers erneut
falken und wieder vorsichtig nehmen und
dann einfach nach vorne schmeißen
und jetzt wieder umdrehen mit den markt
nach unten und so werde ich den teig
jetzt noch einmal abdecken für eine
stunde ruhen lassen und dann kommt noch
mal einfalt und stretch prozess
da
das weiß die letzte faltung und von mal
zu mal wird es auch immer einfacher und
immer besser
jetzt werde ich den teig abdecken und in
den kühlschrank stellen und muss jetzt
noch mal zwölf stunden war so sieht
jetzt der brötchen teig aus als richtig
toll aufgegangen
jetzt werde ich ihn raus stürzen aber
vorher die oberfläche mit etwas gries
bestreuen
das heißt etwa ein bisschen viel damit
eben nicht auf der unterlage klebt und
jetzt nehme ich einfach ein retorten
retter ihr könnt auch ein backblech
nehmen was eben gerade ist ohne löcher
natürlich einfach eine ebene fläche und
jetzt darauf stützen
so und jetzt den teig ein bisschen
ziehen
dieser etwa eine höhe von fünf
zentimetern hat
sträucher auch noch mal ein bisschen was
drauf dann klebt nicht
den teig abdecken und nochmal für etwa
30 bis 45 minuten aufgehen lassen
jetzt ist der teig soweit und ich kann
jetzt endlich wie brötchen formen
ich habe jetzt hier diese große platte
und da raus weil ich jetzt 30 brötchen
bekommen
das heißt ich halte den teig hier
schneiden hier insgesamt sechs bahnen
und hier daneben 5
und die leg ich jetzt mit der oberfläche
nach unten auf ein backblech und da habe
ich jetzt einfach eine dauer back folie
drauf und kann die sog
jetzt verspricht die teiglinge mit
wasser und zwar beugt des ford aus dem
ofen zu sehr ein reisen also sie werden
trotzdem einreisen
aber so bleibt die oberfläche einfach
schön weich und es ist viel wild
besseren backen und ich habe jetzt auch
schon ein scheinchen voll wasser auf den
boden des backofens gestellt das sorgt
noch mal zusätzlich für feuchtigkeit und
so kommen jetzt in den vorgeheizten
backofen bei 240 grad ober unterhitze
mit einem wasser schälchen drunter für
etwa 18 bis 22 minuten bis die
oberfläche schön goldbraun ist die
brötchen sind jetzt fertig das eine habe
ich jetzt auch schon aufgerissen und die
sehen wirklich sehr sehr gut aus und
jetzt gucke ich mal 1 wobei ich habe sie
schon gegessen aber er war super lecker
vor allem sehr kräftig im geschmack und
ich finde das sind einfach die perfekten
sonntagsbrötchen im prinzip könnt ihr
wenn ihr möchtet die brötchen wenn sie
sowieso mit wasser benetzt sind einfach
auch mit mohn oder mit sesam auch
bestreuen und so auch verschiedene
brötchen machen das gesamte rezept
findet ihr noch mal auf cellestis
blog.de und ich wünsche euch jetzt ganz
viel spaß beim nachbacken und ich werde
jetzt den rest hier einfrieren und dann
am sonntag mit zu meiner mama nehmen zum
gemeinsamen familienfrühstück also bis
zum nächsten mal